Well, the,
uh, scimitar right --
you see a weapon
similar to this.
It's essentially
a -- a saber.
It is a type of slashing
and, uh, brawling blade.
It goes by
different names
across Central Asia
and the Middle East.
Uh, in Persia,
it's known as a shamshir.
In India,
it's a talwar.
And what they all have
is a single-edge blade
with a, uh, false edge
back here.
Sometimes
they're straighter.
they widen here,
giving more mass to the point,
very similar to our falchions.
It's not
the most maneuverable of swords,
and of course, this one's
a little bit enlarged
for the armored sport.
But, um, it does have the
capacity to actually turn it,
so that you can slip
that curvature of that point
right down in behind shields,
um, into faces, with thrust.
It's a decent weapon,
and it survived for probably
more than 1,000 years.
It's best on horseback,
camelback.
It's not real effective
against hard armors, though.
It's made for
soft targets.
Blocking situation's
a lot more blade
to block
their blades with.
Um, this does go
naturally up into that --
into that guard,
into the high guard.
You can do a cross guard with
your shield, if you have to.
I gotta be honest -- it feels
a little awkward in my hands...
-Yeah.
-...as far as compared
to the falchion
that we've had in here before,
where it felt very --
maybe because it was
a little heavy on top,
it felt even.
Right.
But this feels
pretty awkward.
Once you get it
against a target
and do that draw,
you have that resistance.
It actually feels
pretty good.
Yeah, you're right now.
And you'll see, uh,
a lot of, uh, period depictions
of particularly calvary charges,
where the calvary officer
is holding his weapon
along this line.
This will tear.
It will do a ripping motion.
It'll go into the body
and then roll out,
tearing out,
gouging out a large --
a large wound
in somebody.
And as your --
as your horse goes by,
the arm goes into this
natural position like this...
Right.
...which allows you
to bring it back on a slice,
or just hold it out
on the side.
It's a little unwieldy.
♪♪